depuis le début de la pandémie les
écarts de revenus de patrimoine ont
grandi de façon marquée selon le rapport
2022 sur les inégalités mondiales
préparé par les économistes thomas
piketty et emmanuel saez gabriel zucman
et lucas chancel plus de cinquante deux
pour cent des revenus sont détenus par
les 10% les plus riches et à peine 8%
des revenus sont détenus par les 50 %
les moins riches et quand on regarde le
patrimoine l'écart est encore plus grand
76 % du patrimoine détenu par les 10%
les plus riches et seulement 2 % chez
les 50 % les moins riches même situation
au canada où les écarts grandissent
entre les plus riches et entre les moins
riches vous voyez les quarts légèrement
s'étendre s'agrandir depuis plusieurs
années rapport importante donc nous en
avons parlé un peu plus tôt aujourd'hui
avec l'auteur principal du rapport lucas
chancel
monsieur chancel bonsoir bonsoir d'abord
ce rapport est une synthèse la situation
des inégalités partout dans le monde il
ya énormément de travail parlez nous un
peu d'abord de l'ampleur du travail de
recherche pour produire un tel rapport
alors c'est plus de 100 chercheurs à
travers le monde qui contribue depuis
des années à cette base de données sur
les inégalités mondiales et ici on
propose vraiment un état des lieux des
inégalités dans le monde entier après le
coc vie donc on s'intéresse aux
inégalités de revenus mais aussi de
patrimoine de genre ainsi que les
inégalités liées au changement
climatique alors dans le rapport les on
voit que les 10% les plus riches touche
52% des revenus alors que les 50 % les
moins riches touchent 8% des revenus et
quand on regarde le patrimoine les
écarts sont encore plus grands est ce
que ces écarts continue toujours de
grandir en ce moment alors c'est l'un
des enseignements de cette pandémie les
locaux vides la pandémie a exacerbé les
inégalités par le haut et par le bas par
le haut les milliardaires de second ont
engrangé plus de 3600 milliards d'euros
de gains de patrimoine supplémentaires
pendant la crise alors que les économies
était un exemple et puis tout en bas et
bien dans les pays en développement dans
les pays émergents plus de 100 millions
de personnes supplémentaires en
situation d'extrême pauvreté donc on
voit bien ici cette polarisation qui est
à l'oeuvre sur un monde qui était déjà
inégalitaire puisque l'un des autres
enseignements de ce rapport c'est ce qui
se passe depuis les années 80 est ce
qu'il se passe depuis les années 80 à
l'intérieur des pays c'est bien la
montée des inégalités notamment des
inégalités de patrimoine et c'est encore
plus flagrant dans le rapport pour
l'amérique du nord les écarts sont
grands d'amérique du nord plus qu en
europe et en asie de l'est ça s'explique
comment
alors ça c'est l'un des enseignements
fondamentaux de ce rapport c'est les
comparaisons internationales
l'amérique du nord était à peu près au
même niveau d'inégalité que l'europe il
y à 40 on est les trajectoires ont été
très différentes qu'est ce que ça veut
dire ça vient en fait que on peut
choisir ou ne pas choisir de suivre une
trajectoire inégalitaire les européens
ont fait des choix politiques différents
des nord-américains et ses choix
politiques différents - induit des
niveaux d'inégalités qui sont autres
donc qu'est-ce qui a été différent et
bien jusqu'à présent les européens ont
réussi encore à maintenir un certain
niveau d'accès aux services publics de
manière égalitaire et équitable à la
santé ce qu aux etats unis le système
santé est très différent de celui qu'on
observe dans de nombreux pays européens
à l'éducation avec une éducation qui est
largement privé en amérique du nord si
vous regardez les pays comme la france
comme l'allemagne comme les pays
scandinaves
c'est l'éducation supérieure de qualité
et souvent gratuites ou à très bas prix
l'accès à la culture au service de
transport etc sont les services publics
qui permettent ça et l'autre différence
c'est comment est-ce qu'on finance ses
services publics quel est le rôle de
l'impôt et quelle est la juste titre
face à l'impôt hélas ce qu'on observe un
peu partout dans le monde c'est pas
uniquement aux états unis au canada
c'est aussi en europe sec une baisse de
ce qu'on appelle la progressivité
fiscale
c'est à dire combien paye les plus aisés
et est ce que ce taux d'impôt est plus
élevé chez les plus aisés que chez la
classe moyenne ou que chez les classes
populaires et ce qu'on voit depuis 40
ans c'est une dégringolade des impôts
payés par les multimillionnaires et les
milliardaires et les entreprises
également vous dit que ce sont des choix
politiques et que lise n'égale it et ne
sont pas finalement inévitable et on
voit aussi que les états sont de plus en
plus pauvres justement parce qu'ils se
privent de l'outil fiscal parce qu'on a
beaucoup baissé les impôts
alors on parti pris on se prive de
l'outil fiscal puisqu'on était dans
cette logique de ce que certains ont
appelé la théorie du ruissellement c'est
à dire penser que si on réduit les
impôts sur les très riches tout ira bien
l'emploi va être créée il y aura de
l'investissement l'économie sera
dynamique moralité c'est pas ça qu'on
observe c'est que cette théorie du
ruissellement elle ne ruisselle russell
vers le haut si vous voulez le l de
russell que pour les plus aisés et le
l'appauvrissement des états c'est quoi
c'est ce qu'on vient de raconter mais
c'est aussi des privatisations c'est à
dire des actifs des entreprises qui
auparavant étaient possédés par l'état
qui pouvaient en bénéficier et qui sont
vendus souvent à bas prix au secteur
privé qui va faire de juteux profits
bénéfices sur sur ses ventes et puis
c'est aussi la hausse de la dette
publique la hausse de la dette publique
contribuent à appauvrir les états et
cette dette c'est aussi un poids
politique qui est donnée à ceux qui vont
la détenir cette dette est ce qu'on a vu
pendant le covin c'est quoi ces quinze
points de pib supplémentaires de dette
que l'état contracte auprès du secteur
privé est la question qui se pose
aujourd'hui c'est comment est-ce qu'on
va la rembourser cette dette et qui
valent à rembourser est ce qu'on demande
aux jeunes générations qui ont été
frappés de plein fouet par la crise de
rembourser la dette dans dix ans dans 15
ans dans 20 ans ou est ce qu'on demande
aux multi millionnaires et aux
milliardaires qui se sont très bien
porté depuis 40 ans qui ont aussi
engrangé tous ses gains pendant la crise
de contribuer un peu davantage voilà les
questions qui se posent à nos sociétés
après dix-huit mois après deux ans de
vide et c'est très fondamental d les
points pour terminer ce qui est
intéressant dans votre rapport c'est que
vous montrez que les gens les moins
riches émettent peu de gaz à effet de
serre et que les 10% les plus riches et
mettre beaucoup même qu'en amérique du
nord ses 73 % des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre c'est important de
montrer ces données qui émet des gaz à
effet de serre dans la société
oui parce que si on n'a pas en tête ces
informations de base alors on peut se
tromper dans les réponses que l'on
apporte aux changements climatiques
si les politiques environnementales les
politiques climatiques comme par exemple
une taxe carbone ne prennent pas en
compte cette inégalité là alors ça peut
créer des tensions
assez importante on l'a vu en france
avec la crise des gilets jaunes il y a
quelques années à une taxe carbone qui
était très impopulaire parce qu'elle
touchait les catégories les plus
modestes de la population ceux qui
émettent peu mais qui était très touché
par cette taxe il ya d'autres manières
de faire on peut mettre en place des
taxes carbone ou va redistribuer une
partie des recettes de cette taxe la
colombie-britannique notamment utilisent
ce type de mécanisme c'est intéressant
il ya aussi d'autres mécanismes et le
fond du message c'est que on ne pourra
pas accélérer la transition climatique
sont davantage de redistribution des aux
pollueurs et des hauts patrimoines vers
les classes moyennes et vers les classes
populaires merci pour ce rapport
beaucoup d'informations très
intéressantes merci monsieur chancelle
merci à vous pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit
oh